♪ ♪
>> THE GLOBAL EMERGENCY ON
JANUARY 17TH.
AND THAT WAS DECLARED BASED ON
EXPERTS.
I THINK WE DECLARED AN EMERGENCY
AT THE RIGHT TIME.
AND WHEN THE WORLD HAD ENOUGH
TIME TO RESPOND.
>> Laura: THAT WAS W.H.O.
DIRECTOR GENERAL FORMER WHO
MARXIST REVOLUTIONARY.
WE GAVE YOU THAT EXPOSE THE
OTHER NIGHT.
AND JUST TODAY, HE OFFERED HIS
DEFENSE OF HIS HANDLING OR OF
COURSE MISHANDLING OF THE
CORONAVIRUS OUTBREAK.
THIS COMES A WEEK AFTER
PRESIDENT TRUMP PUT A HOLD ON
THE FUNDING FOR W.H.O. WHICH IS
GREAT NEWS, GIVEN THAT
ORGANIZATION COMPLICITY AND
CHINA’S OPEN COVER UP YOUR
JOINING ME EXCLUSIVELY AS
SECRETARY OF STATE MIKE POMPEO.
MR. SECRETARY, THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE TONIGHT.
EARLIER THIS WEEK, HE SAID THE
GLOBAL COMMUNITY SHOULD DEMAND
THAT TEDROS ADHANOM AND HIS
CRONIES RESIGN IN ORDER TO JUST
GET THIS BEHIND EVERYONE.
WHAT IS THE STAY -- STATE OF
PLAY WITH THE RELATIONSHIP RIGHT
AT THIS MOMENT WITH THE W.H.O.?
>> LAURA, THANK YOU FOR HAVING
ME FIRST OF ALL, THE PRESIDENT
HAS STOPPED ALL U.S. FROM THE
WORLD HEALTH ORGANIZATION AND
COMPLETELY APPROPRIATE GIVEN THE
RECENT HISTORY.
LAURA, YOU HAVE A SOPHISTICATED
SET OF VIEWERS THAT REMEMBERS
THIS IS NOT THE FIRST TIME THE
WORLD HEALTH ORGANIZATION HAS
FAILED TO DO WHAT IT NEEDS TO DO
WHEN A PANDEMIC BEGINS TO BREAK
OUT.
IN FACT, I’M VERY WORRIED THAT
WE ARE STILL NOT GETTING IT
RIGHT.
SO YOU RECOUNTED WHAT HAPPEN IN
JANUARY THE 8TH DELAY OF THAT
ANNOUNCEMENT AND CHINA AND THE
WORLD HEALTH ORGANIZATION DID
NOT DO THAT BUT EVEN TODAY
THE CHINESE GOVERNMENT HAS
PERMITTED AMERICAN SCIENTIST TO
GO INTO CHINA TO GO INTO NOT
ONLY WUHAN LAB WHERE EVER IT
NEEDS TO GO TO LEARN ABOUT THIS
VIRUS, TO LEARN ABOUT ITS
ORIGINS.
WE KNOW IT BEGAN IN WUHAN, BUT
WE NEED TO FIGURE THIS OUT.
THERE IS AN ONGOING PANDEMIC.
WE STILL DON’T HAVE THE
TRANSPARENCY AND OPENNESS IN
CHINA.
AND IT IS THE WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION TO ACHIEVE THAT
TRANSPARENCY.
THEY ARE NOT DOING THAT.
THEY NEED TO BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE.
WHAT IS GREAT TO SEE THE
COUNTRIES BEGIN TO RECOGNIZE
W.H.O.’S FAILURES AS WELL.
>> Laura: THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY, MR. SECRETARY FOR
THE UNITED STATES TO TAKE THE
LEADERSHIP ROLE GIVEN THE
CLOSENESS THAT THE W.H.O. HAS
WITH CHINA, WHICH SPENDS A
FRACTION OF THE MONEY WE HAVE
BEEN SENDING TO THE W.H.O.
SO GIVEN ALL OF THIS, GIVEN
EVERYTHING THAT HAS HAPPENED,
SHOULDN’T TEDROS BE CALLED ON TO
RESIGN BEFORE WE GO FORWARD AT
ALL IN A RELATIONSHIP WITH THE
W.H.O.?
>> I THINK WE HAVE TO TAKE A
REAL HARD LOOK AT THE W.H.O. AND
WHAT WE DO COMING OUT OF THIS.
LAURA, WE REFORMED THIS BACK IN
2007 SO THIS IS NOT THE FIRST
TIME WE’VE HAD TO DEAL WITH THE
SHORTCOMINGS OF THIS
ORGANIZATION THAT SITS INSIDE
THE UNITED NATIONS.
WE NEED TO FIX, WE NEED A
STRUCTURAL FICTION FOR THE
W.H.O.
>> Laura: IF WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT REAL ACCOUNTABILITY HERE,
THE GUYS LEAVING THE
ORGANIZATION I DON’T SEE HOW HE
CAN BE PART OF THE SOLUTION.
SO TONIGHT YOU ARE NOT RULING
OUT THAT THAT MIGHT BE ONE OF
THE REQUIREMENTS FOR GOING
FORWARD WITH THE W.H.O.
YOU ARE NOT RULING THAT OUT.
>> NO, I THINK THAT IS RIGHT.
LAURA, EVEN MORE THAN THAT.
IT MAY BE THE CASE THE
UNITED STATES MAY NEVER RETURN
TO U.S. TAXPAYER DOLLARS.
WE NEED -- MAY NEED BOLDER
CHANGE THAN THAT.
>> Laura: MAKE OUR OWN
ORGANIZATION.
SENATOR TOM COTTON WROTE A
PHENOMENAL PIECE IN
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL"
YESTERDAY SAYING THE U.S.
GOVERNMENT IS INVESTIGATING WHAT
COVID-19 CAME FROM A GOVERNMENT
LAB IN WUHAN AND CIRCUMSTANTIAL
TO BE SURE, IT POINTS TOWARDS
THE WUHAN LAB.
CHINA ABSOLUTELY DISAVOWALS ANY
CULPABILITY FROM THAT LAB.
AS DOES THE CHIEF SCIENTIST,
WORLD-RENOWNED SCIENTIST WHO
RUNS THE LAB.
SHE SAID THE SAME THING IN
INTERVIEWS LAST WEEK.
DO YOU AGREE THOUGH THAT THIS IS
WHAT THE STATE OF OUR
INFORMATION NOW IS AT THIS LAB
WAS THE SOURCE OF THE VIRUS THAT
HAS DONE HUGE DAMAGE AND LOSS OF
LIFE IN IN THE UNITED STATES?
>> LAURA, WE DON’T KNOW
PRECISELY WHERE IT STARTED.
THAT IS THE CORE PROBLEM.
CHINA KICKED OUT JOURNALISTS
WHEN THE UNITED STATES AND
PRESIDENT TRUMP TRIED TO GET IN
TO CONDUCT AN INVESTIGATION THAT
STILL NEEDS TO BE UNDERTAKEN.
IT STILL HASN’T BEEN DONE.
WHEN WE TRIED TO DO THAT, THE
CHINESE DENIED ACCESS NOT ONLY
TO THE LAB BUT THE WET MARKETS
AND ALL THE PLACES ONE WOULD
NEED TO GO TO TO IDENTIFY THEIR
ORIGINAL SOURCE FOR THIS VIRUS.
WE ARE STILL TRYING TO GET THAT
INFORMATION.
WE ARE STILL SEEKING
TRANSPARENCY.
>> Laura: YOUR PREDECESSOR
COME I KNOW YOU ARE TEXTING
PALS, JOHN KERRY CLAIMS
MR. SECRETARY THAT WE NEED TO
ENTANGLE OURSELVES EVEN FURTHER
WITH CHINA GOING FORWARD, WATCH.
>> WE HAVE TO WORK WITH CHINA.
YOU HAVE TO WORK WITH CHINA ON
COVID-19, ON ALL PANDEMICS.
THE SECURITY CHALLENGES OF THE
REGION.
YOU HAVE TO WORK WITH CHINA ON
CYBER AND CYBER WARFARE.
RIGHT NOW COME I THINK THE
PRESIDENT IS ALL OVER THE PLACE
AND EVEN ACTING IN THE WRONG
DIRECTION.
>> Laura: CYBER WARFARE?
[LAUGHTER]
WE HAVE TO WORK WITH CHINA?
SECRETARY POMPEO, WE ARE GETTING
DRONES FROM CHINA TO SPY ON
AMERICANS CITIZENS OF THE MAYOR
AND LOCALITY.
BUT JOHN SAYS KEEP IT GOING.
>> I AM NOT SURE WHERE TO BEGIN,
LAURA OTHER THAN TO SAY THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS TAKEN
FUNDAMENTAL DIFFERENT VIEW WITH
CHINA THEN PRESIDENT OBAMA DID
AND SECRETARY CARRIE DID,
WHETHER IT WAS THE TRADE
RELATIONSHIPS AND ATTEMPTING
TO UNTANGLE OR SERIOUS WITH
CHINA WENT CONDUCT CYBER TEXT
AGAINST US.
WE WILL NOT TOLERATE THAT.
HERE EVEN IN THIS, WE WOULD LOVE
TO FIND A WAY TO COOPERATE WITH
THE CHINESE.
FRANKLY I’M ON ALL THOSE THINGS.
BUT IT TAKES A PART OF WHO IS
WILLING TO DO THAT AS YOU
DESCRIBE HERE THE BIGGEST THREAT
IS THE ABILITY TO WORK WITH
CHINA AND CYBER IS TO MAKE SURE
WE HAVE THE RESOURCES AVAILABLE
TO PROTECT OURSELVES FROM
CHINESE CYBER ATTACKS.
THESE ARE THE KIND OF THINGS
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS TAKING
SERIOUSLY, AND WE HAVE TO MAKE
SURE WE RECOGNIZE THE CHALLENGE
THAT CHINA REPRESENTS TO AMERICA
AND WORK WITH HIM WHERE WE CAN.
SNOW AND I HAVE TO ASK YOU IN
CLOSING, MR. SECRETARY COME ABOU
TWEET FROM PRESIDENT TRUMP
EARLIER TODAY.
HE SAID I INSTRUCTED THE
UNITED STATES NAVY TO SHOOT DOWN
AND DESTROY ANY AND ALL GUNBOATS
IF THEY HARASS OUR SHIPS AT SEA.
THIS CAME AFTER IRAN HAD
SUCCESSFULLY PUT INTO ORBIT WHAT
IS CALLED ITS FIRST, I GUESS ITS
FIRST SATELLITE MILITARY
SATELLITE HOURS BEFORE THE
STREET.
SO WHERE DO THINGS STAND AT THIS
HOUR?
THAT IS A PRETTY SERIOUS THREAT
COMING FROM THE UNITED STATES.
WHAT’S NEXT?
>> IT IS PRETTY SERIOUS.
IT IS A COINCIDENCE THAT YOU
ASKED THAT QUESTION RIGHT ABOUT
TALKING ABOUT JOHN KERRY.
YOU WILL RECALL OUT UNDER THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION
SECRETARY CARRIE TOOK OUT THE
NAVY AND APOLOGIZE TO GET THEM
BACK.
THIS IS A DIFFERENT APPROACH
FROM THE PRESIDENT.
HE TAKES SERIOUSLY THE
OBLIGATION TO PROTECT THE FORCES
WHEREVER THEY MAY BE.
IN THIS CASE ON NAVAL SHIPS AND
ARABIAN GULF.
WE WILL DO EVERYTHING WE CAN TO
MAKE SURE WE DEFEND OUR FOLKS
AND CONTINUED TO DETER ISLAMIC
REPUBLIC OF IRAN.
THE LAST THING TO SAY THEY
LAUNCH THIS MILITARY SATELLITE
TODAY AND PROMISE THEY WERE IN
TILE THE McINTYRE MISSILE
PROGRAM WITH CIVILIAN AND THE
PERSON WHO OVERSOLD THIS LAUNCH.
THIS IS THE SAME FELLOW WHO
FORCED TO SHUT DOWN EIGHT
AIRCRAFT KILLING 176 AND SIX
INNOCENT CIVILIANS JUST A FEW
WEEKS AGO.
>> Laura: HOW COMFORTABLE ARE
YOU DEALING WITH KIM JONG UN’S
SISTER IF FOR ANY PERIOD OF TIME
SHE BECOMES THE LEADER OF THE
COUNTRY GOING FORWARD GIVEN THE
CONCERNS THAT SOME ARE
EXPRESSING ABOUT KIM JONG UN’S
HEALTH RIGHT NOW, MR. SECRETARY?
>> I DID GET A CHANCE TO MEET
HER A COUPLE OF TIMES.
THE CHALLENGE REMAINS TO SAY
THAT GOLD REMAINS UNCHANGED.
WHOEVER LEADS NORTH KOREA WE
WANT THEM TO GIVE UP THEIR
NUCLEAR PROGRAM AND JOIN THE
LEAGUE OF NATIONS.
WE WANT A BRIGHTER FUTURE FOR
THE NORTH KOREAN PEOPLE.
THEY HAVE TO DO NUCLEAR ICE AND
HAVE TO DO SO IN A WAY WE CAN
VERIFY.